southern nevada resident living on a
boathouse on lake mead says he is a
victim of the drought craig miller's
boat got stuck after he pulled up to
shore for repairs but the water level
receded too fast we spoke to him today
on the plans to get him off dry land
i just got a traveling instead of a vote
now
it's a harsh reality for craig miller's
eyes his houseboat he recently purchased
to kick start his retirement is far from
what he dreamed of his nightmare he says
began on june 4.
props got out for some reason
i
took the water off looking at it what
not drifted in the store
miller says the water level receded
while he went to find the tools to
repair the problem over the last three
weeks he has tried several options but
each one was either too expensive or
crews did not have enough resources to
pull his houseboat it's a combination of
things
being in the wrong place at the wrong
time
miller's two friends from tucson are in
town to help get the houseboat stuck
south of calville bay and lake mead back
on the water this is home yes that's the
thing so throughout us we've had several
decades you know as i was referencing
before um it gets it's hot it's brutal
it's 118 degrees the wind's whipping you
know we've got a foot john boat
we're moving equipment we're
it's harsh conditions i mean i'm
sunburned according to national park
services miller was in the process of
moving his vessel before his marina slip
expired when he got stuck he's got until
june 24th to remove it before park staff
removes it i always got in trouble my
motor wouldn't have died i've been fined
and i wasn't
i didn't think just a little more it
would go away
so i brought my phone i wasn't really
worried about it
well miller tells us he is meeting with
the professional rescue team right now
although there is no guarantee he is
he says he is hopeful that he will be
back on the lake very soon